[Musique]
ces courtisans faut il rappeler déjà
très bien que c'est ça ça fait le record
du monde de rapidité et five ouais on a
fait on n'a pas le record du monde mais
on peut le faire très vite c'est vrai
que contre les façades ont fêté un
copain carte sim et ses danses de notre
registre si c'est parti mais politique à
la télé qu'il est passé bien les mecs
sont trop chaud non mais vous êtes trop
chou ce talent et ça c'est pas partie et
puis tu es prêt au lit mais politique à
la télé qui débattent et des vidéos riba
décousu plein les bottes et les patates
de bâle en tête et les bavures et des
balles qui se perd dans le bâtiment
c'est devenu banal des pays qui la
bagarre pour une histoire de paquets de
café le fameux tout le monde devrait
également voir demain quel degré dans
une cave demandé de vie de ces sacs pour
quelques dollars
des bannières aux baléares avec sa bande
de potes et dans cette époque où t'as
pas de milliers de billets t'es pas
pourquoi je pille et emilie faut
remonter
c'est un ancien des morceaux n'est pas
de la tarte est prêt à tout pour
embarquer à la cagnotte à nantua
[Applaudissements]
que les ché
les polonais sont avec nous j'ai alors
regardé beaucoup l'émission nous a collé
c'est raynald pouvoir réagir